welcome ladies oh it's just me Nikki
Bella where's Lana
oh oh well Nikki Lana what uh hello
Nikki welcome she got stuck I think in
traffic or something you guys didn't
come together no we had well we were
together earlier and we got separated
and so I think she might have are you an
argument Carson are you tag team
champions what Lana and I I think we're
the future tag team champions we asked
because the wrestling fans like you that
I always ask to basic I'm not familiar I
ask the basic question there's there's
this Instagram that I have seen a lot
over the past like six months and that's
like their hope and dream is to have
Lana an ID tag champions look is that
right yeah it's great oh they like
Photoshop us and all this stuff together
and we'll see you but you are you're not
done wrestling no I'm not done I I
definitely want to come back I'm right
now I have to take time to heal and I
don't know how long that will be what
happened I might a slight herniation
above where I had surgery so if there's
any further impact then that's going to
get fully herniated and we know that
surgery again so I have to take time and
chill and let that heal and you never
know how long that can take but I'm
hoping by the time I heal my sister has
already popped that baby out and is back
into brie mode shape and we could take
it you know come back as a tag team and
have some fun did you get engaged I did
who's your fiance is he a wrestler you
know this guy's a sweet guy named John
Cena Oh Jenna he goes did you did you
how much of a feeling did you have that
it was coming because like I had the
feeling it was coming right well I mean
I heard all the speculation right I
heard everything I knew about the prop
bets but you know why like it was funny
my sister my mom and I were talking and
I was like John would never do this like
he's a private person there's no way
that he would propose to me in front of
all these people and I was actually kind
of embarrassed how many people were
asking me about it because I'm like
here's here it is again everyone's gonna
think I'm going to get proposed to and
I'm not because he proposed to her after
their match at WrestleMania so they
wanted tagged WrestleMania just happened
yeah yeah so and you know if you go back
and look at John's entrance he gets
surprised
when he's in the ring well his mom was
ringside and John and I had no idea she
was going to be at the event she's never
seen him wrists alive ever so why was I
like it no she just you know she doesn't
travel a lot and it's just it's she
likes to give John his space when it
comes to Debbie to be and likes to watch
on TV that's always her thing so she's
right there ringside and we had to go
over and give her a hug so even when he
grabbed the mic after the match I'm like
in my how to go what a swerve everyone
thinks he's gonna propose and he's going
to be like all the years I've been at a
Wrestlemania on a show my mom has never
sat ringside in here she is I'm thinking
this is what's going to happen and now
when he goes into coal and goes on to
talk him like to me like I just I
couldn't even breathe right like if you
go back I'm like breathing so heavy and
I don't know how do you know it's not
just a part of the show they like all
the sudden you'll show up to the church
and like you be like what are you doing
oh yeah yeah were you worried that like
he was like you proposed to you and then
you're going to get backstage and he's
like as a good like no sir for the crown
you know the one thing is John and eyes
love is so real and I couldn't even
listen to the crowd because I was so
lost in his eyes and the words he was
saying talk to him
yeah right it was a very real moment and
I think what's cool too is them that
ring is home for John and I like w2b is
our family it's our home no matter where
we go in life that is home and there was
something that felt so right and perfect
when he proposed to me I mean this is
where we met and we have built a lot of
memories and I don't know it just felt
so perfect well for you yeah you guys I
mean you do wrestle it makes a lot more
sense than somebody who's like a regular
guy getting putting on the scoreboard am
i exactly right or like hey we're at a
basketball game this is my favorite team
but my wife doesn't care and so I'm
gonna propose it we want to match like I
mean listen think of what I could tell
Brees kids you know like hey so I won
this match I got to be at WrestleMania
Annie proposed who is brie mark I don't
hear I don't want Jerry to pot oh nice
yeah married she is to Daniel Bryan you
ain't know I was okay oh yeah yeah yeah
he's been in here before to get any
retire yeah he did okay
yeah so she's having a baby that's great
the first one
yeah first oh cool very gel baby girl
okay check before yeah that's smart
yeah a lot of people now are not like
more and more people are not I'm sorry
to hear that yeah I think it reversing
now yeah yeah what a surprise it but
it's easier to get you know you can kind
of get settled in you know what you're
gonna have yet we've got a name
immediately you did yeah and as we could
yeah you have to well you can pick a
name if you buy clothes you decorate the
room well for a baby doesn't matter
aren't the clothes kind of do they go
boy and girl when you're like yeah I
mean it's so fashionable now like you
have super trendy girl stuffs and guys
stuff like Brian had to give me a talk
of like because he's very against
consumerism and he's like look you can't
just buy birdy a ton of stuff and I'm
like are you kidding me I am like I'm
her auntie Coco but he like tries to put
rules on me he doesn't want her to see
my dressing room I'm like who's Brian my
knight older husband his name Daniel
Bryan so the bell of famine is John and
I and then brie and Bryan oh okay yeah
Daniel Bryan but sorry I calm brain okay
yeah that's his real name
did you ask John if he was going to
propose to you at WrestleMania based on
the fact that there was so much
speculation you know I actually it's so
funny a few weeks before I go have you
seen what's been online and he goes no
what
and I'm like everyone thinks you're
going to propose to me at WrestleMania
because I'm like how am I not going to
ask him right and he goes well that
means we're telling a good story kid and
I was like yeah that's right cuz we're
on the middle of historian is Maurice
you know are throwing in my face about
not getting married so I was like there
was good point the whole build-up you
didn't see the whole build-up to this
match for Wrestlemania what the bad guys
were telling Nikki that she was never
going to get married John Cena was it
was like the most personal REO like oh
man Briana it's a great talent how long
is dating or how long were you dating
four and a half years also no yeah yeah
is Miss a good guy or a bad guy always
there is he all of them I mean it's the
best but he's a bad guy are you so you
gotta get married on TV now you get the
gallery show yeah I do and so you know
I'm gonna have to put some thought into
that not going to say an immediate yes
because the one thing is is
I don't want to take away the most like
special important day in my life I want
it to truly be special and all that
stuff and I would love to showcase that
on TV so we'll have to just think and
talk about it have you ever been married
before
well kind of we mean kind of kind of so
it's a long story and if you would have
saw season one or two of total divas
my parents had to find out for the first
time on camera which they were not too
happy about but so I my high school
sweetheart he joined the military and he
like we just we I thought that okay if I
marry him like maybe he won't have to go
to war or blah blah blah
it was so stupid in what were we 19
why'd you think I won't work what's
amazing yeah I don't know I thought like
a week they're not gonna let a married
man go to war
no no married man it doesn't
eighteen-year-old said right and we
drove to Vegas I married and in tell
anyone you did no research on that
though it make sense in me we were
married you that yeah yes yeah wait you
were married
oh yeah Lana just walked in by the way
yes I was just asking she's ever been
married before I didn't know if she'd
been married before
oh I didn't know that either yeah I was
19 to get a gown Vegas on no one knew
except for Bri nice and no one knew up
until like four three years ago you get
it annulled or just different yes yeah
no actually it was a simple divorce I
think is what they called it because I
waited past years so I couldn't get in
an old I guess Oh cheers every year I
was like - can you do it I only I only
saw him like five times after that so I
was like um it's kind of like you have
to work even though he was married
little more yeah that way my night
earlier on yeah 19 year old head I
thought I thought I was doing right by
him and I'm really cool that you got
married in Vegas I always kind of like
yeah my pocket would be like I was in
hugs my hair was thorough not no makeup
and it was Elvis I think that's the
greatest reason I've ever heard you they
won't send a married man now all these
letters have gotten written back over
the years yeah I miss you baby
naive I was like are you married you're
a giant ring yes I am married I had two
weddings I married to the Bulgarian
brute rusev is he a wrestler yes yes
he's a big Bulgarian brute the big bad
guy is Adam wrestling yes okay actually
met him on my first day and NXT on my
first day of starting in the next two so
Mary wrestlers just because I mean
obviously they're in good shape and
they're like the type of guys that
you're in you're around the mold I guess
an accountant would have a hard time
dealing with your life you know yeah
yeah well we're around each other a lot
but you know I like to you know I guess
is going to be a girl thing but I
believe in fate too
so I think like oh you know it brought
us here we met each other but I mean we
are around each other was 300 days years
right right so there's a lot of couples
at WWE I mean look at total divas alone
you have Renee and Dean Ambrose you have
Trinity and John and you have brie and
Bryan and Lana and rusev and John and I
and Mis Amore's everyone is like a
wrestling couple yeah yeah Charlotte was
in here and Jim was trying to figure out
it's like maybe he had a shot with any
other wrestling women yeah but Charlotte
just said a lot of them were
unfortunately coupled off already
yeah but isn't she single she's single
and I am single so there you go yeah not
not that she's a new Samoan that's
crushing everyone yeah I Jackson yeah
you're beautiful she's yours all right I
I might be too old for her whole to see
I'm 48 how old is she
um Western yeah she's very prudish yeah
dobe you dirty woman 2 yeah yeah yeah I
do like that you don't mind it yeah
carry me around a little guys now by the
Charlotte I had like some weird vibes
nice wife yeah we got a nice I really
wasn't I mean their vibes were weird but
it wasn't she was lovely upper to you
it's like giving her like the good guy
and she was like what is he doing yeah
no I'm the opposite I'm like it's a
radio show that's unprofessional just
for your cutting keyboard you've got the
flirtation was too heavy on her and I
didn't care for tonight I understand
like I'm a person I'm an object did you
think a lot of when you started doing
total divas like it's always been
interesting I think with you because
like Lana plays this Russian character
on WWE who's got this like heavy accent
and she had never broken character
before the reality show
and so she pops on the reality show she
breaks character but still at with the
Nate like you're still Lana though yeah
not CJ well yeah I mean I go by the name
Lana on the show and but I feel like I'm
kind of glad I waited that long because
I feel that people took my character
seriously and would have been would have
been just too confusing for our fans to
hear me speak perfect English but I
consider myself Russian American because
I'm an American but I grew up in Russia
so identify to Russians I was her
Russian school I never had prom and
we're in Russia Latvia to be exact a lot
of people think Latvia is Latvia and
Louisiana so that's why I say Russia
Latvia one of the fence anyone I ever
met was from Latvia really yeah I think
she was a dancer in that movie shoes
from Latvia winning movie the white
chicks incorporated that horrible my dad
you should see Lana dance you good
answer I'm an amazing that what do you
do i I do tap I wish I went to the
Gregory Hines school what are you doing
get you out right now by the way that I
found out who my stepdad Johnny
Laurinaitis no you need to get him in
tap shoes what a crazy yeah he did it
growing up what are you doing kind of
dancing well I started off with doing
ballet de ballet I was like professional
ballerina ten years old
gotcha yeah the beginning and I do
everything I do break dance play right
good yeah I try I got old in you I will
say Jim does have one thing that he he's
pretty good at from that world yeah I'm
a big pop Walker back in the old days do
you remember Beach Street and break in
those are great Marianas on our green
moon you want to pop lock for no because
I hurt my shoulder landing awesome like
was disrespected yeah but you can pop
lock oh yeah I could that's so hard and
we have a dance battle right now I'll
probably lose I'll come be for sure um
fresh it all pretty sure I could
probably yeah yeah mr.keshe pop luck I
haven't seen ever seen a she's a good
pop lock off lock-in oh yeah yeah I mean
a stand up though yes I can't do it
there she at all my head involved too
how do you not make the noise
what noise I'm not a how to make your
suppose I am NOT and the doorknob lock I
do like that's so cool exactly glad
actually I would kind of think you might
you might have one that I don't want to
insult anybody I wouldn't in that yeah
you did the flowing thing which is like
pop lock 101 I did the complicated oh
you did I am yes the robot it's really
really important yeah you a ballerina
you a breakdancer modern dance
contemporary hip-hop twerking to twerk
of course against work this is well
before you wrestle yes oh yeah so how
did you get involved I think that
actually is what got me my job because
when I did the Diva Search I walked in
and I remember triple Eight's sitting
there and all of creative and everyone
and build them on at the time and I came
in with like a dress and high heels and
I started speaking Russian and then I
switched the perfect English and they
all start smiling I'm like oh perfect
and then I'm like I can breakdance
and they go to do it and I started break
dancing in heels no skirt so yeah but
never you love it well I'm going to use
the Russian thing stay tuned why don't
they not raw and total divas I guess so
I guess dancing is makes you more limber
in the ring probably - yeah like Lynn
Swann from this dealers from our old man
reference you take ballet because it
would make them a better drivers into
that right absolutely wow that's amazing
like she wore your dextrous yeah it
gives me a lot of places to evolve -
that's true of all these skills there
yeah no way can I get on your toes can
you stand on your toes and dance yeah
that looks ok I do that once in a while
I just want to see like what I don't
stand no no but I'm looking finding out
new things I had no idea that things
yeah that's one of the more massive
things I've actually said on this show
but the fact that people can do that
I've stood on my toes for a second like
I don't know how anybody dances like
this you try though like you're watching
on YouTube and be like oh I wonder how
that feels
no I just don't know just one of those
things it looks like it's really painful
yeah have you seen those images of
ballerinas when the shoes are off that's
partly yeah we're feet are all your feet
up yeah
my feet are tired now but when I used to
do point like 40 hours a week they were
all blistered and all those those aren't
ladies feet
that ballerina oh yeah that's like this
is totally normal like all of it would
be completely blister blister blister
blisters that what your feet look while
it's just on the top you're not they're
better now they're better now yeah so
what I was doing is just like pain you I
don't know I guess I feel like they say
wrestling's not ballet but the thing is
you go put your body through so much
pain in ballet that I think it kind of
does makes you more pain tolerance
really for wrestling and also build
discipline in you so she's a Russian so
you would get you would get blisters oh
yeah
that's normal like all of them would
just be bleeding hmm
you just put bandaging up and she's
going if you don't someone else is going
to get the job so you better keep
pushing through watch your spike that
also translates into WWE doesn't it hold
it onto your spot oh yeah yeah oh yeah
okay you do you want - you haven't
really wrestled since what was that last
year WrestleMania breeze last night -
yeah why'd you stop wrestling well I
didn't stop wrestling just kept on
training and I want to start wrestling
when the time is right so stay tuned are
your just training training training
yeah I'm training in the next team I go
down there pretty much on all my off
days and then I'll try to do as many NXT
shows as possible so you're also married
to a wrestler who is rusev but we found
out about it on TMZ hmm was it difficult
because like you're your characters on
the WWE TV show not married
yeah but then TMZ post this photo which
I mean maybe w/e knew about I don't know
where you guys are together now you're
married so now the audience it's like
super confused because they're like wait
but I saw them on TMZ married yeah what
was it was that difficult to kind of
figure out how to deal with um I mean I
think what was difficult is that all of
a sudden the story ended but I mean what
are you gonna do you just have to take
it and be like okay I mean I'm not the
director of Vince McMahon's the director
and he makes the shot so whatever he
decides I go okay great thank you thank
you for the opportunity and I make the
most of it oh yeah so that would do they
see that on TMZ and go we're not going
to we're going to go in the opposite
direction then if that's on TMZ kind of
um that's I was injured so I wasn't even
there at the time but I think he just
said he wanted to make a story out of
that I see
I don't sound like you try to dance but
you're really bad and you can't pop or a
lock or breakdance your solo I'm not
even going to say that words because I'm
a lady
but yes the worst is we come on that one
man
whatever someone does a voice and then
just tells you what they wanted to say
okay right it is very good I love being
a bad guy so much fun I was hanging a
friend of mine I hung out with yesterday
she speaks Russian she's from life in
Moscow where st. Petersburg where it's
just a very difficult language it
doesn't sound like a compassionate
language even I'm sure it doesn't sound
like people it's hard to sound like
anybody is really sweet in that language
it's not a French or Italian no no
actually the hardest language in the
world right after Chinese and Japanese
yeah oh wait harder than English you
somebody again somebody knows somebody
Russian people - somebody sent me a
YouTube clip of myself doing stand-up
but they had Russian dubbed over it but
Russian this in a lot of time will just
talk over the audio it's not like a dub
in this is always so really you can
actually hear it's really funny because
that's kind of how I started learning
Russian when I was seven rush TV and I
can hear the English and if they just
dub over fell over it and it's just one
voice the whole time like a man's voice
she came home she said you hear things
with almost two ears like yeah you can
hear the underlying Russian and you hear
the American over or under it it was so
weird to hear myself and I can hear my
voice under it but then this Russian you
say don't want to they want to laughs or
whatever to be there yeah it was weird
yeah popular music the pardon sorry Wow
she was insatiable yeah give to worries
out like how you know that the jokes are
actually being said properly or not I
have to keep the laps in yeah I hope
they're being improved upon fixing all
your punch line yeah it would be funny
to use translating my jokes wrong yes
and just humiliating me oh just doing it
himself
yeah yeah there's a hole like that
yeah this was a funny one have you do
you know when you're going to get
married yet no I don't know I'm taking
it like of course I mean I've already
like been scrolling through my phone
like oh I like this date or I like this
data I'm like John so what do you think
about the spring or the fall and he's
like just take it all in right now I'm
like okay I need to do that yeah enjoy
all my girlfriend says it takes about
three days till it finally feels real
so today's pretty much third day the
feel real not yet I'm still in shock
yeah you know amazing look at that ring
I know you for gigantic it is my car
laughs yeah I mean my wife noticed too
she was like oh my god it says Tiffany
on the inside of the box like she was
watching the WrestleMania so dishes your
wife realized that she married on the
wrong side of the wrestling are you
going to uh do you think you have a
giant wedding you know I I think you
know as you get older like when you're
younger you want to have this big
wedding you think of it as this big
party but I think I just kind of want to
keep mine intimate like right good
friends and family I mean but my Italian
side that makes the party of the guest
count already at 150 so I just but I
want it to be intimate you don't want it
to be fun and most importantly I don't
want John to have to worry about people
wanting autographs or photos or worrying
about people taking photos of him I want
it to be as one night that he could just
be normal around family and come back
exactly right so the play here's what
Tim was asked well I just I mean because
it could be like a work thing to like
where like you want to get married at
SummerSlam because I've been seeing that
a lot no but will Sam be invited to the
wedding that's basically I don't even
think of that but I guess no Sam is kind
of in the wrestling world he's a big fan
and he kind of I am there yeah he's
there you know what's going about it on
to the he know you took yeah I'll think
about it it was coming because when John
and I were walking to the bus after we
ran in the big show and he's like I
better be invited and he had to like
tell us like four times and John's like
all right man but you know I just I'm
gonna have to think about she's gonna
think about my think it's probably
looking towards favourable I've never
heard she was actually more
complimentary to my pop-locking
receptive to your wedding position solid
damage I like them till you not going to
the wedding
well we'll see if I was going oh then
all I have to watch it on total divas
total divas by the way our total balance
rep total divas total divas is back
tonight yes iam on e we have to let you
guys go to your next interview okay well
thank you guys for having us again tune
in tonight you're going to see Bulgarian
wedding this season by the way that's
fantastic and my comeback on SummerSlam
so there's a lot of exciting mm well
I'll be watching I hope I got the bottom
of some things the wrestling fans were
annoyed but I don't know a lot about
wrestling I hope I am good I hope you
pop rocks to get stuck in it I hope I
get annoyed all of them